This video is brought to you by opera.
Hey, wisecrack, Jared here, let me ask you something.
If you had the chance to wipe out the worst thing that ever happened to you to
make it so that you had no memory of the event at all,
would you do it or more importantly, should you,
these are the questions at the heart of today's movie,
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind first released in 2004.
This lasting film opened to rave reviews, charmed by innovative cinematography,
unusual structure and an all-star cast critics and audiences alike fell in love
with this quirky haunting story about the nature of human relationships and
heartbreak. But after 16 years, does the movie holdup was Kate Winslet,
just lucky enough to cash in on the manic pixie dream girl phenomenon before it
got stale,
or is there something really profound about the relationship she and Jim Carrey
portray on the screen to answer this question,
we have to get to know the uncredited star of this movie,
the human brain specifically,
we're going to look to neuroscience to examine what this film says about the way
the brain works and what that means for us as human beings.
Living with those brains sound complicated.
Smithies this isn't rocket science it's brain.
Don't worry.
We'll break it down for you in this wisecrack condition on eternal sunshine of
the spotless mind,
deep or dumb and spoilers ahead for one of the few movies ever to put Frodo
Baggins in the hope in the same room.
I haven't really had much luck with the ladies and maybe we stop stealing their
panties.
But before we get into it, I want to give a shout out to this week.
Sponsor opera. We're all online a lot these days.
So why not have the best browsing experience possible?
Opera is the all-in-one browser that gives you features to connect to your
favorite platforms and make your time online, more productive. For starters,
you can design the way you want your browser to look and organize all your tabs.
There's also workspace a feature that allows you to create and customize the way
your tabs are saved for optimal workflow.
Opera also features integrated messengers. So you can access Facebook,
messenger, WhatsApp, and telegram all on the side.
So you don't have to check every app individually. While browsing.
You can watch videos from Netflix, YouTube,
or almost any other video provider with the browsers video pop-out tool.
They even offer a built-in VPN and ad blocker,
which saves you the headache of downloading extensions and keeping track of
subscriptions. Opera includes all this and more,
which you can check out for yourself by downloading the browser today,
you can download opera for free by clicking the link in the description.
Once you've downloaded it, let us know what your favorite feature is.
If you're watching on mobile,
you can still click the link in the description to download later.
So make sure you use our link. And now back to the show, all right, guys,
let's do a quick recap. Sad sack.
Joel bearish wakes up one day to find a huge scratch on his car.
And most of his journal entries missing on whim.
He ditches his usual commute and hops on a train to Montauk where he meets and
starts to fall in love with the quirky and impulsive Clementine Christian ski.
After some jumping back and forth on the timeline,
we discovered that Joel and have actually met before. In fact,
they've had a whole life together dating for what appears to have been several
years.
Neither lover recognizes the other because they independently arranged to have
their memories of the painful relationship erased by a company called lacuna,
Inc.
The film cuts between Joel's bedroom were Lacount technicians are working to
wipe memories of Clementine from his brain and the inside of his head.
As he changes his mind about the procedure and fights to keep those memories
safe while Joel and Clementine do ultimately lose their memories of each other,
they managed to retain a vague impression of their feelings,
which sends them to Montauk at the same time. At the end of the film,
it's heavily implied that the whole cycle of their relationship will begin again
to discern whether the film is deeper, not.
We need to dive into some philosophical and ethical questions about the proper
use of technology and our Nate human abilities.
When it comes to building our identities,
selves and experiences at a very basic level,
the movie's plot is driven by Joel's choices about what to do with his brain.
That is whether or not to eliminate Clementine from his consciousness.
He starts off wanting to alter his brain even to the point of harming it in
order to avoid the pain of having loved and lost Clementine.
Is there any risk of brain damage? Well, uh,
technically speaking, the procedure is brain damage, but it's,
it's on a par with a night of heavy drinking, nothing you don't miss.
As he goes through the night and starts to realize what losing Clementine really
means. The eradication of a huge part of his life and emotional experience.
He makes a choice to fight the procedure and preserve as much of her as he can
paint and all.
Call it off.
Those decisions, boil down to a choice between comfort and growth.
He can live a diminished but easy life without Clementine or opt for a harder
but richer experience with her in it.
But this is also a choice between two ways of approaching his physical brain,
either as something to be trimmed down and controlled for the sake of efficiency
or something to be used for its full messy potential,
whatever the consequences of that growth and freedom might be philosopher.
Catherine Malibu has written about this exact dilemma in her conveniently titled
book. What should we do with our brain?
The book draws on neuroscientific research to discuss the concept of the brain's
plasticity. When we say plasticity,
many of us are actually thinking about the far more limited and nefarious
concept of flexibility.
Plasticity involves adaptation and according to Malibu is an agency of
disobedience to every constituted form.
Our refusal to submit to a model to be flexible is to receive a form or
impression to be docile, to not explode. Put it another way.
Research and experience show that our brains are able to both adapt to
circumstances and resistant to work with change and to create it to
borrow Malibu's analogy.
Ourselves are like plastic explosives able to mold to a given shape if
necessary, but also capable of radically changing our own form.
And that of our environment flexibility on the other hand involves always taking
the path of least resistance. Look from this point of view,
Joel's decision to erase or keep his memories of Clementine can be seen as a
choice between exercising the full plasticity of his brain or doing the flexible
thing by destroying those parts of his brain that are making you uncomfortable
in both Malibu's book and eternal sunshine.
Flexibility is presented as the guiding philosophy of neoliberal capitalism.
According to both techs,
we live in an economic system that demands flexibility from its actors and
offers them products and services,
which will increase their flexibility for price eternal sunshine,
perhaps simplistically portrays business.
As the process of taking advantage of people who are suffering from confusion or
pain.
Joel's very first lines frame Valentine's day as a corporate plot to sabotage
our emotional state.
Today is a holiday and admitted by greeting card company to make people feel
like crap.
But the film ultimately earns that critique keeping with the same theme.
The movie makes it clear that lacuna Inc survives by profiting off of people's
desire to rid those crappy feelings of heartache. As Mary points out.
I told him pre Valentine's day is our busy time.
Okay? It's even implied that clients may become dependent on the memory erasing
procedure over time and will go to extreme lengths to get it done.
No, I'm sorry. You can't have the procedure done three times.
The ways in which the company takes advantage of compromised,
people become less subtle and more disturbing.
As the film progresses shortly after arriving at Joel's apartment,
the lacuna Inc technicians assigned to wipe his memories,
turn his home into their own personal Airbnb, drinking, getting high,
and even having sex near his unconscious body.
This trend takes a turn for the seriously up.
When we learned that one of the technicians stole a pair of clementines
underwear while there were erasing her memory, I mean,
they were cleaned and all,
and that he's been using information stolen from Joel's letters to try and trick
her into falling in love with him. The unethical behavior reaches its climax.
When we find out that Howard coerced, Mary,
his own secretary to wipe her memory after the two of them had an affair
together.
Oh, hell yeah, we agreed it's for the best.
What Joel Clementine and lacunas other customers lack that leaves them open to
such exploitation is the flexibility that society demands of them.
Such a demand.
According to Malibu is at odds with our true nature as human beings,
as beings with plastic brains, we can indeed bend when we wish,
but we're also capable of resistance creation.
And other acts of free will in the face of obstacles do often know in a culture.
So tightly focused on work and productivity.
The full plasticity of our brains is reduced to the concept of flexibility and
presented simply as the possibility of increasing or decreasing performance.
Very often the brain is analyzed as personal capital.
This idea of the brain as personal capital,
something you can optimize and invest in for greater output,
like a factory production line is even more prevalent today than when Malibu
first wrote about it.
In 2008 in Silicon Valley and beyond we find workers taking drastic steps to
alter their brain functioning for improved performance on the job orders engage
in so-called brain practices, find tuned, sleep and break schedules,
the use of nootropics and even LSD microdosing in an attempt to put in longer
hours and produce more work, whether or not this serve their own health,
wellbeing, or growth.
These practices and others are examples of Malibu's flexibility,
inaction hijacking your own brain chemistry to meet an unreasonable deadline,
demonstrates a profound ability and willingness to adapt to circumstances rather
than improve them from an economic perspective.
Then to be flexible is to upskill,
reorient and change as often as necessary to satisfy the demands of society,
rather than take the drastic action of trying to change those demands.
Lacount ink promises its customers.
The flexibility that is so highly prized in our society and economy without
their procedures done,
Dr. Howard's patients are inflexible fixated on past lovers, dead pets,
or any of the countless disappointments and setbacks that are part of being
human. He explains his service to Joel as a way for people to become unstuck,
not by overcoming the challenges they face.
Kinski was not happy and she wanted to move on.
We provide that.
But by smoothing out their lives so they can continue forward uninterrupted.
When you awake in the morning,
you find yourself in your own bed as if nothing in her
discussion of.
Mood, regulating drugs,
like Prozac Malibu claims that our society commonly judges,
such treatments based on their ability to reduce vulnerability,
chronic disturbance and psychical precariousness,
and give back the appetite for mobility,
the capacity to rid oneself of rigidity and a fixidity in one's identity.
In other words,
we say that a psychiatric drug or treatment is working when it makes the person
using it more flexible in their approach to work relationships, et cetera. Now,
this is not to say that Malibu Malibu's against such medication.
On the contrary, she makes a point of saying how useful it can be.
She's simply pointing out that the discourse around the effectiveness of
psychiatric medication tends to focus on whether it makes the person more
pliable, productive,
and eager to fit in rather than on whether it helps them be more strong-willed
creative, et cetera.
Howard's procedure can be thought of as just such a flexibility enhancing mood
stabilizer. In some sense, he is a modern day.
[inaudible] cutting out those parts of the brain,
which are thought to be the source of uncomfortable unproductive feelings like
sadness, depression, or anxiety.
When the wider system demands its individual members adapt.
No measure is too extreme.
What unites Howard's patients or his target demographic is a desire to shortcut
the hard work of integrating negative experiences into their lives.
So they can go back to living in a way that doesn't require change.
They want to express flexibility rather than plasticity and Howard is willing to
help them do.
It now, or just makes it all go away.
Clementine poignantly expresses this understandable wish to wipe away
difficulties while describing her childhood.
My favorite is this ugly girls doll like called Clementine.
And I keep yelling at her. You can't be, be pretty.
It's weird. Like if I can transform her,
I would magically change too.
If as Malibu claims, trying to magically change ourselves,
by being eternally accommodating is a waste of our true potential.
Then what should we do instead?
What would a fully realized plastic brain and self actually be like in
other words,
if we choose not to automatically go along with the demands to be flexible,
then what is the alternative we're fighting for? According to her,
the plasticity of the self implies balance between the preservation of constancy
and the exposure of this constancy to accidents to the outside,
to otherness in general, she adds that if we didn't explode at each transition,
if we didn't destroy ourselves a bit, we could not live.
The simplify Malibu claims that to be really human to express plasticity is to
balance the need to adapt against the need for growth and change. Yes,
we all decide to make sacrifices for the sake of productivity.
From time to time,
we might stay late at the office for one night because the boss asked us to or
skip out on movie night with friends because our teacher wants that term paper
submitted by midnight.
But when we become so flexible that we iron out every inefficiency in our lives,
when we're so afraid of explosions, that we take no risks,
then we're in trouble. In other words,
the spotless mind from the Alexander Pope poem that gives the movie its name,
isn't a desirable thing at all. We need our spots, traumas, heartaches,
et cetera,
in order to live full lives that have some meaning outside of our ability to
satisfy demand.
How happy is the blameless vessels? Lot
the world forgetting by the world for God,
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind,
each prayer accepted in each wish resigned.
So what do we do as individuals in a society that demand,
we stamp out the troublesome,
unproductive parts of our brains in order to succeed,
how should we make the best use of our brains?
That is how do we accomplish the most cyberpunk of goals that Malibu sets up in
her books, opening pages, neuronal liberation. Her answer is symbol.
We ought to refuse to be flexible and exercise the explosive creative dimensions
of our brains plasticity to the fullest extent possible as she puts it,
we should visualize the possibility of saying no to an afflicting economic,
political and MediaTek culture that celebrates only the triumph of flexibility,
blessing obedient, individuals who have no greater merit than that,
of knowing how to bow their heads and smile.
Joel Clementine and Mary take up this fight by pushing back against the eraser
of their own and other's memories that is by being difficult and refusing to let
things run smoothly. For the sake of smoothness.
Joel demonstrates plasticity by working with his projected image of Clementine
to evade Howard and his technician.
What if you take me somewhere else,
somewhere where I don't belong and we hide there till morning.
When it becomes clear that he won't be able to run forever.
Joel even manages to seed a subconscious direction for his waking post-procedure
self again, via his image of Clementine.
While Joel wakes up and follows his subliminal urgings back to Clementine Mary
rage, the lacuna Inc offices,
and sends out all of their files to their previous customers in effect,
ruining the procedure for all of them and upsetting the smooth operation of the
company.
My name is Mary [inaudible] we've met, but you don't remember.
You don't remember me.
I worked current com hire tired to have part of your memory erase.
With their painful history. Thus revealed to them.
Present a Joel and Clementine must decide whether or not to pursue a
relationship together knowing in advance that they are likely to hurt each other
very badly. Their choice is the film's ultimate example of plasticity inaction.
That's the other thing that I don't like about you, but you won't,
but you will know you will think of things and I'll get bored with you and feel
trapped because that's what happens with me.
The flexible thing for Joel and Clementine to do in this situation would be to
accept the futility of pursuing a relationship together and go their separate
ways to live comfortable, productive lives,
either alone or with better suited partners.
Instead they willingly blow up their chances at untroubled singledom or
functional romance opting instead for a dynamic,
which has been empirically proven to not work inherent in our plasticity is the
ability to make choices of our own free will perhaps especially when those
choices don't make much sense.
The film's final shot is a looping clip of Joel and Clementine playing on a snow
covered beach in Montauk implying that this cycle is likely to play itself out
again, their relationship isn't perfect. It may not even be a good idea,
but it is their choice made in defiance of flexibility and therefore an
expression of the brain's plasticity that is its vast potential to create and
destroy both itself and its environment.
These neuro rebels have done Malibu proud and they've earned themselves a solid
deep from us.
But what do you think wise crack are there ethical or practical limits to how
much we can and should optimize our brains for given purposes,
have a favorite movie or TV show that explores how people relate to their own
minds.
Let us know your thoughts in the comments below a big thanks to our amazing
patrons for supporting our channel and the podcast hit the subscribe button and
as always, thanks for watching guys. Hey.
[Inaudible].